bonjour eric zemmour dit bonjour nous
nous retrouvons dans un format un peu
nouveau confinement oblige et le sujet
du moment c'est la facilité avec
laquelle les français ont accepté des
mesures de confinement qui pourtant sont
très contraire aux libertés
individuelles
est ce que cette acceptation vous a
surpris je suis très frappé dans tous
les pays d'ailleurs au delà de la france
il y à une acceptation une soumission à
ce qui est quand même la privation de la
liberté la plus élémentaire c'est à dire
la liberté d'aller et venir
alors je sais bien qu'on qu'on donne
toutes les meilleures raisons du monde
que c'est pour la santé tous et c'est un
jeu
je ne vais pas du tout aller en sens
inverse je dis simplement que je suis
très frappé d'abord par l'acceptation
global même s'il ya des exceptions
et surtout est ce qui me frappe encore
plus c'est les médias qui y sont à
aarhus piller les autorités parce
qu'elles ne sont pas assez sévères et à
vitupérer la population en disant mais
c'est pas du confinement etc
il ya une espèce de voiliers de pousse
au crime médiatique
je trouve ça assez intéressant sur les
mentalités collectives et sur ce que ça
révèle alors on peut noter au passage
que le président de la république a
peut-être plus de facilité à décider le
confinement des français que la
fermeture des frontières et alors ça on
voit les ravages de l'idéologie je
dirais européiste et sans frontiérisme
qui atteint jusqu'aux plus hautes
autorités de l'état c'est à dire qu'il
n'a pas voulu fermer les frontières
alors qu'il a finalement accepté la
fermeture des frontières de schengen
comme si l'europe avait une frontière
mais pas la france
très révélateur aussi de la mentalité et
deuxièmement qu'est ce que c'est d'autre
que le confinement qu'une frontière
personnel qu'on s'enferme chacun et on
réinvente les frontières d'origine que
j'allais dire de l'humanité à l'aube de
l'humanité sert chacun se défend contre
tous alors que justement la nation était
la façon la plus la plus civilisée de
sortir de cette guerre de tous contre
tous
on se souvient tous des leçons de offs
donc ça ça me fera beaucoup et on voit
bien que dans tous les pays c'est la
même chose par exemple en angleterre où
boris johnson a beaucoup scandalisé en
refusant ce confinement générale en
disant que bon le virus devaient devait
passer
et finalement il s'est résolu il a cédé
il s'est soumis à cette règle du
confinement générale le 21 mars je crois
est le seul journal anglais qu'il ne les
qu'il ne l'ait pas des kings qui n'est
pas défendu ce confinement
c'est un journal comme le daily
telegraph qui de la droite conservatrice
et qui a titré ce que je trouve très
beau the end of freedom et ce qui est
terrible c'est qu'on sait que ce
confinement général est une mesure du
moyen-âge qu' il n'est là que pour
pallier nos carences dire que si on
avait fait assez de test et on avait
assez de masquer on avait assez de
d'appareils respiratoires comme en corée
du sud
on n'a pas besoin de ce confinement
général voyez c c est ce que finalement
les français sont plus attachés à
l'égalité qu'est la liberté selon vous
alors c'est la vieille thèse tocqueville
yen qui est de dire que les français
préfèrent l'égalité à la liberté ce qui
est très probable mais regardez en
angleterre où c'est l opposition
classique entre les anglais et les
français les anglais préférant l'égalité
à la liberté à l'égalité
là aussi ils se résolvent finalement au
confinement et à la fin de la liberté
donc je crois que c'est encore plus
vaste que ça vous semblez considérer que
cette privation de liberté que vivent
les français est en quelque sorte la
conséquence ou le prix à payer de notre
des classements économiques pourquoi
c'est à dire que six ans dans les pays à
la pointe technologique comme la corée
du sud comme taïwan comme ou même israël
vous avez vu les mesures de confinement
général sont remplacés par des mesures
de ciblage de tests généralisée de masse
que maintenant recommande l'om est
d'ailleurs un mois après la bataille et
de de masques pour tout le monde
et de cible ou savez on suit à la trace
grâce à la géolocalisation en
géolocalisant vous avez trouvé le bon
mot en géolocalise
on suit à la trace tous les gens parce
qu'en fonction de ce qu'on a vu et les
les ceux qui sont affectées doivent
comme ça à dire qui ils ont vu baisser
des mesures beaucoup plus alors vous
allez me dire c'est aussi des mesures
coercitives ces mesures étaient aussi
des mesures liberticides
mais je trouve ça moins que je ne sais
pas pourquoi je peux le confinement
général ça permet au moins de cibler les
choses et on voit bien que les pays
européens qui ont pris un retard fou
dans la recherche médicale qui ont
d'autre part sous traité à la chine
toute leur industrie médical que ce soit
les masques les appareils respiratoires
tout ça donc on compte qu'on ne fabrique
plus ou presque plus et quand les
chinois évidemment on a besoin pour eux
ils ne viennent plus et là on est
dépendants
comme comme jamais donc c'est pour ça
que je dis ces mesures de confinement
général sont là pour compenser un
déclassement économique technologique et
finalement d'indépendance nationale
merci eric zemmour